hey we also need to talk about the cups
because you guys drink the cup Oh God
then as the show you know we get more
into the real world these cups are
following you everywhere there every day
there's love potion in those I don't
believe I know what is the story behind
the cups well you know when you're
filming TV you know you're drinking
concentrate like the continuity edit
right yeah that's what I thought but
that's not on the show they could take a
break yeah thanks it was my idea it was
not my idea
those look like the type of cups that
keeps a drink at the temperature it
should be I think they are just like a
memory like yeah I think the number one
question we got for you is an update on
your Cameron's relationship with your
dad because it was very real on the show
yeah but now it's a year and a half
later where do we stand
yeah yeah I mean I love your dad yeah I
love Lauren's dad I mean he was over at
the house right before we left
he's at our house now watching our dog
yeah yeah is he shook by this whole
process
um the process yes originally because I
mean it is kind of a crazy process like
you meet someone through a wall and get
married and my dad is like you're crazy
what's wrong with you but at the same
time I trust your judgment and I'm gonna
support you so and me and my dad are
like super super close so I feel like he
acted like any father would like worse
he's protective of his baby girl you
know like who is this guy like I have to
make sure they treat you right like
that's the most important thing to me
but I'm gonna grill them what are those
dads do anyway like work yeah yeah but
things are good Sunday dinners like he
cost cam his son cuz he is you know and
so um we have so many we got literally
over 3,000 questions for you you guys on
it I will get to them but I have one
question that is an internet conspiracy
theory that I don't need you guys to
torture I don't
there's a lot of speculation around
whether or not Nick and Vanessa Lachey
we're actually at the experiment or they
were superimposed up afterwards we're
actually there put it to rest were they
there yes okay we also one more question
for you the projection x-ray it was like
a hologram
one more question can you guys believe
how many celebrities have started
watching the show it's my desire s
Chrissy Teigen Kelly brought it all
Miley Cyrus just seen the tweets yes Wow
Wow yeah
Kerry Washington yesterday because we
something about us dressing up like
scandal else kill me like I woke up that
morning I was like dead oh my god it was
so well done from an Instagram from mkf
what has been one of the most
challenging aspects of watching the show
almost two years after the event
mmm challenging I would definitely say
reliving some of the like emotional
emotions you know like just being scared
or happy like every time I cry in a
scene like I cry watching it takes me
back there especially like the scene
with me and my father and my wedding
like I cannot watch that and not cry
yeah with the logistics of the wedding
like how did you really get all your
friends and family there on such short
notice
it was hard that's why even like on the
show I was struggling like how do I
invite my whole family first off I have
to explain to them the process of this
so I was just like frustrated I was
scared so for me I just chose him by
like my closest family and friends and
like you know we'll have a reception
later where we can invite everybody and
it's easier now because the show's out
so yes wow that kind of sucks everyone
loves you guys on the show and that like
truly America's Sweethearts patrulla
there's anyone who the way they came off
on the show did not represent who you
know them to be from filming
I don't know I mean with Damien's story
and and kind of to the earlier question
- it was a little bit hard to watch
because you know I just
you just hate to see your fellow cast
mates like going through these fights
right it was just really hard to watch I
had to kind of walk away a couple times
when we watch it yeah but you know I
obviously didn't see him and Gia Nina's
relationship like we thought on the show
so it seemed different to me then and
watching it from a third party at the
time like seeing him going through it
and being very upset and you know
pushing and trying to make it work and
all this yeah now at what point on your
wedding day did you find out about the
other couples who had made it or didn't
um we actually did it like they kept all
that from us until after everything
wrapped and then we were able to like
reach out to other people like hey how
did it go oh that's so Vinny so we
wanted us to kind of stay isolated and
focus on us so yeah like the other
people can even we couldn't go to each
other's weddings or anything like no
yeah they definitely weren't on the same
day everyone had their own dates I have
another question because on watch
happens I've last night where you guys
looked great and you did great and II
asked you guys a bunch of questions and
he was like who was like the least
shocking to you guys that didn't work
out and you said you everyone pretty
much knew Kelly and Kenny like weren't
gonna make it but for the audience like
we were shocked I was like there's no
idea people are getting out how what
what what did you feel like wasn't right
between them hmm I mean just from being
like an outsider
I don't know I'm all about and I I can't
just I don't know them but just from
being outside I'm all about chemistry
and energy and I don't know I felt I got
a friend vibe from them yeah they were
really romantic and affectionate a lot
and I think I'm sorry some relationships
just aren't like that so that doesn't
necessarily mean anything but I don't
know I just didn't get like oh I'm so in
love with you from there
I think that was the case that there was
a mutual respect there for each other
and I think they loved aspects of each
other but the romantic part yeah right
because you know I was actually thinking
that you can go through the pod process
and come out with a really good friend
oh yeah for sure I'm just connecting
with someone emotionally exactly yeah
you need the physical component too
right yeah and that's like me and Mark
like we had a couple of days we would
just be laughing and stuff and me and
Mark her friends now but we knew it
wasn't romantic
same thing with Damien yeah but I think
in the pods it's probably hard to
decipher like do I love this person or
like are we just really getting along
right well I knew I loved different you
know what it's like okay this is a
friendship we're joking this is like a
brother and sister thing you're just
like yeah like really in touch with your
emotions I think - yeah that's all on
the show oh absolutely and vulnerable
mature I think it's a scary thing like
you have to be open to be like well this
could really be something
because how me it's like it's easy to
get in your head like no this is a show
this is a wall I'm not really about this
I mean seriously like I'm not really
about to open myself up to this but if
you're really open and really searching
for the things that you want and you
really realize like this is a good
connection like let's pursue this and it
makes all the difference
did you do your own glam for the dates
and for your engagement and I did I did
that was you looked great
loved your haircut yeah so sophisticated
thank you you know I tried I was I tried
I did my own toolbox I figured I didn't
even have to ask
who was your guys's favorite couple
besides yourselves during the whole
process like couple double date partners
[Music]
none of them well I mean we we love them
all individually I think as a married
couple we would probably go out on a
double date with Amber and garnet you
just laugh at them all day do either of
you keep in contact with diamond and
Carlton yeah we do very tumultuous very
um yes what are your guys thoughts on
that whole situation it
it was tough to see yeah you know I was
Carlton's roommate on the show diamond
we kind of bonded in the pods to and a
more of a friendship sort of way so I we
didn't want to see that go down at all
and you know I knew about Carlton's
sexuality but I was just hoping that it
was gonna go yeah so it was that was
another one of those scenes where I was
like man I was slipping that was out of
control I will say one diamond was
singing those Beyonce lyrics though I
had a bowl a girl you better quilt yeah
yeah oh my god that's so funny wait one
more question
you said Carson was your roommate what
were the living conditions like was like
a bunk bed no well we were at the
facility I don't know what else we can
say okay they're cozy uh cozy in what
way
comfortable tight-knit okay I spend so
much time in the pods because you did
want to go back to your living yeah in
the park yeah I have another question
about the liquor was there wine and
liquor in the pod there was yes but
there was also other things in the past
where there was like shoes I'm a snacker
yeah but I think you're like having a
glass of wine would like really help you
open up especially every legs cuz it's
kind of like an intense process you know
a little social lubrication I like to
call it I tried to keep it like how did
you both get on the experiment mm-hmm um
well they had a casting so it just went
through that process you have to take a
psych exam for those like you know the
cat this is crazy you could be marrying
some crazy persons like no they test for
that
and you know we had to do like Skype
interview so that we can talk to the
producers telling what we want what
we're looking for how is our dating life
been and work for you I think the best
part of the show compared to other
dating shows that I watch and I do like
I just find a lot of the times like the
TV show element takes over and people
are so excited to be on TV that they're
not actually looking for love yeah and
to me love is blind was the perfect
formula because everyone on there was
like of an appropriate age like ready to
get married really ready to be committed
there was no one who was like afraid of
commitment right that's you wouldn't
have gotten on the show if you all right
yeah I think that was the real
expression you know it's refreshing to
see real people on TV acting like real
people yeah as opposed to like overly
produced or like that's all fantasy yes
the situation's were very real Olivia
real conversations though yeah yeah
setting a wedding exactly okay I know
you guys are so busy just being
America's Sweethearts running around
town thank you so much for stopping by
we really wish you nothing but like
happiness lunch Appetit thank you and
thank you guys for listening to the
morning trust we will see you tomorrow
with the lady gang bye
[Music]